I'm really insecure about my back hair I
hate talking about sex with other dudes
sometimes I dance alone in my bedroom to
Britney Spears oops I did it again
bless me Father for I have sinned
these are my confessions I've had my
wedding planned in my head since 1988
strip clubs freak me out one time I
looked in the mirror to see if I had a
thigh gap
I loved fall but only because pumpkin
spice lattes are back I don't understand
why people just don't buy me flowers why
is that another thing I really want to
be engaged I only pee sitting down I got
a pedicure once it was delightful why
can't I wear pink it looks great on me I
don't want strippers at my bachelor
party I just want to hang out with my
friends I've cried during every Air Bud
movie he's a hero why the [ __ ] should I
have to know how to change a tire
sometimes I wish someone would buy me a
drink I don't like how other men talk
about women's bodies I don't like it
I think [ __ ] are gross I've never
said this but I I know it to be true
you've got mail is a better movie than
Citizen Kane I'm not allowed to say that
but it's a fact I tell people that I'm a
Miranda but I'm really a Charlotte